PIERRE ETTORI: Good
afternoon, and thanks
for joining us for
this presentation.
Today we are going
to be presenting
how Google is helping companies
to revolutionize how they
consume and deliver
application in the cloud
by enabling a service-centric
approach to networking.
We will be presenting how
Private Service Connect
and Service Directory allow
us to connect seamlessly
and privately to services
and manage them at scale.
My name is Pierre
Ettori, and I'm
a product manager at Google
Cloud and Private Service
Connect, and with me is Matt.
So from an agena
point of view, first
we will be looking at the
challenges of consuming
services at scale
[INAUDIBLE] to talking
about this service-centric
networking approach
that we will be leading and
introducing Private Service
Connect and Service Directory.
And finally, we'll be bringing
Private Service Connect
and Service Directory
together and see
how they are better together.
Business leaders
across industries
are prioritizing growth,
innovation, and time to market.
In fact, in a recent
study, 94% of the CEOs
indicated that at least two
of the top three business
priorities depend on how well
technology team are executing.
So the responsibility to
deliver services faster
is increasingly being
placed on their shoulders.
This is a huge
responsibility that
needs to be met with the
right tools and software
for them to be successful.
Many CIOs acknowledge that
migrating to the cloud,
adopting new application
architecture,
and building cloud
native services
will help them jump start growth
and accelerate them to market.
However, 80% of them report
that despite having migrated
a portion of their
application, they
have struggled to achieve
the desired level of agility
and business benefits.
In conversation with
technology leaders,
three main points come
up again and again.
Number one, complexity and
slow speed of migration.
Number two, they
want to modernize now
so they can increase efficiency
without business disruption.
And number three, they
want to consume services
faster and focus on
value-added services.
So companies are trying to
consume more and more services
faster so they can deliver
on their business priorities.
But as we have seen,
many of those companies
are also admitting
that they haven't
been able to completely
unlock the full potential
that the service
consumption can wreak.
One of the reason is that
consuming services securely
and at scale exposes a lot of
complexity on how we connect
to them and manage them.
And we're going to look
at it first in terms
of connecting to those
services and then
on how to manage the application
and services at scale.
And connecting to services
at scale is complex today.
Cloud and network
architects had to do
a lot of preplanning
and engineering
to expose services privately.
They typically had to
exchange infrastructure
global information,
like IP addresses
and subnet coordination with
technology like DPC pairing,
so different domain
could communicate.
Or they had to manage
complex routing topology.
They also had to do that
across different organization,
networks, accounts, making
things a lot more complicated,
especially for regulatory
reasons or security
best practices, the enterprise
wants to keep the services
completely protected
from internet
and only use private
IP addresses.
Finally, it is not only
about how to consume services
but also how to
deliver services.
And we are seeing an explosion
of different type of services.
Some are single-tenant,
some are multitenant,
some are on-demand, and
some are pre-established.
So connecting all
those services at scale
securely and privately
while enabling innovation
in simplicity is really complex.
And the other complexity,
slowing down companies
to deliver on agility
and faster time to market
is managing services at scale.
As more and more
teams and companies
are consuming and
delivering services,
we have seen an
explosion of technology,
focusing on service
consumption from cloud
and SaaS vendor or
new services framework
like microservices architecture.
And it is all for the best.
However, it came at
the cost of having
to manage all services at scale,
especially in this world which
is multi-everything, like
multi-cloud, multi-environment,
and multi-environments we
took about on-prem or GKE
or serverless function.
Well, we are also multi-cluster
and multi-languages.
So the explosion of services,
framework, and platform
is making the discovery and
publishing of those services
complex, especially
because it needs
to be done in a way that is
not stifling the creation
and growth of those services.
Teams should be
evolving independently,
choosing the best platform
with delivery mechanism
for their needs, but really
leaving DevOps or cloud team
with the really complex task to
enable this exponential growth,
while at the same time keeping
system in control and secure.
And finally, as we have seen,
if the cloud engineering
team ends up spending a
significant amount of time
mastering complexity
to managing services.
As the scale increase,
it becomes harder
to stay as productive.
And yet we are putting on
their shoulder a lot more
responsibility,
the responsibility
to deliver those key services.
So we need to make sure
the cloud engineering
team can stay focused and
productive on value-added task.
So mastering complexity
versus extracting simplicity
means being able to
rethink the primitives
that one exposes
to actually truly
empower the agility and
velocity organization they're
working for.
And extracting simplicity
means rethinking
the complexity exposed from
the underlying platform.
And many of our
technology have evolved,
starting with infrastructure.
And so a lot of the
complexity come from that--
come from those
system that are still
exposing infrastructure-centric
networking,
instead of focusing
on services delivery.
And so at Google,
we are delivering
a service-centric
networking approach
instead of the
infrastructure-centric
so enterprises and end user can
focus on connecting, consuming,
delivering, and managing
services securely at scale.
Services-centric
networking solution
focus on services
connectivity and management,
without having to
worry on the complexity
of the underlying
infrastructure.
Organization can finally execute
on the [INAUDIBLE] innovation
and enable technology teams to
deliver and consume services.
Since the underlying
infrastructure is not exposed,
the connectivity and
management of services
become much simpler,
secure, and private.
It accelerate the
migration to cloud,
since companies can connect
simply from on-prem to new
services in the cloud faster,
while enforcing the security
standard and best practices--
for example, leveraging
private IP space.
Finally, by simplifying
the management of services
at scale, it enable
enduring team
to execute and innovate faster.
And so with that, we
are excited to present
our service-centric networking
product, Private Service
Connect, to connect privately to
services, and Service Directory
to manage and then reduce
their services at scale.
As you may have seen during
the keynote from earlier today,
we are excited to present to
you Private Service Connect.
Private Service Connect allows
to connect and consume services
easily and privately to many
different type of services.
By focusing on
service-centric networking,
Private Service Connect abstract
the underlying infrastructure
for both the team consuming
and delivering services,
which greatly simplifies
how they connect
and access services.
It is doing all of that
using private connectivity,
meaning the traffic is never
exposed to the public internet.
And finally, it drastically
simplified the communication
and upfront planning necessary
to build network architecture
that used to happen
with technology
like [? VPC ?] pairing.
So Private Service Connect
offer us many advantages,
and we can--
we're going to look at that
in more deeper details.
First, Private Service Connect
enable to consume services
faster, meaning on one
side, consumer of services
can operate independently
from producer of services.
They don't need to pre-agree
on the routing or subnets or IP
information.
And we support any
type of tenancy
for the delivery of the
services, can be single-tenant
or ridge multi-tenant services.
Private Service Connect really
enabled a private and seamless
connectivity.
For consumer, it becomes
really easy for them
to [INAUDIBLE] to those
services because they just
need to create an
endpoint on their network.
It feel it belongs to them, and
that's the only configuration
they have to do.
They don't need to talk more
to the person delivering
that series.
They just create an endpoint
and now can connect to it.
And as we have seen,
it's private end-to-end
connectivity.
The traffic never has
to go in internet.
It is all secure, meaning
the companies tenders,
so security's tenders, that are
so important to move to cloud.
And finally, it really
accelerate cloud consumption
because it enabled to support,
really, any type of services.
Could be first party
Google services,
like Google Services
at Google API.
It would be third-party
partners or vendors
offering the services.
And it would be also the
customer-owned services
that they are
delivering internally,
making that communication
faster and the delivery better.
Private Service Connect
has been build and designed
for security, scale,
and performance.
Security, as we have been
talking over and over,
is a big, big theme
for enterprises
to be able to move to cloud.
And especially as
[INAUDIBLE] consume
and we consume more
and more services that
are production-ready,
you want security.
You want to feel that
that traffic is secure.
And with Private
Service Connect,
all the traffic stays on Google
backbone and is encrypted.
And it is leveraging the IP
addresses of both the consumer
and the producer, really
feeling that they are leveraging
the private IP spaces.
It's scaled for
enterprise grade solution,
meaning we can support thousands
of Private Service Connection
to services, greatly, greatly
simplifying the type of designs
where scalability
and quotas or things
like that were a concern.
And finally, in
terms of performance,
Private Service
Connect has been build
with no proxy or
middle boxes as part
of the solution it is truly
line rate, really allowing
the consumer and the producer
to access each service as if it
was VM-to-VM traffic,
and so really thinking
in terms of performance here
so we can support, really,
as many type of
services and performance
[INAUDIBLE] services.
So if we look a little bit in
more detail of Private Service
Connect, you will
see how simple it is.
We have talked so far about the
consumer side and the producer
side, and we're going
to reuse that here.
If we look first on
the right-hand side
of the slide with a
producer, a producer
is offering a service
behind the load balancer.
That service could be
any type of services.
The only thing that
the producer needs
to do to enable
Private Service Connect
is to create a
service attachment.
And a service attachment
is a new type of resource
that's really simple.
It just has a name.
It has an IP from
the producer network,
so it belongs on that IP space.
And we have built a lot
of [INAUDIBLE] information
in governance to make
sure that the connectivity
to that service is
going to be secure
and following the
company best practices.
On the consumer side, on
the left side, the really--
it becomes really
simple for them
to consume a service because the
only thing that they have to do
is actually create an endpoint
that would have a target.
And the target would be
that service attachment
and on top of
that, it would have
an IP address from
the consumer IP space,
again, highlighting how
consumer and producer don't
need to really pre-communicate
or pre-agree on anything.
The consumer use whatever
is its own IP space,
and the producer use
whatever is its own IP space.
And there is no
coordination needed
to connect a consumer and a
producer service together.
So really, as we have
seen, for companies
to fully take advantage of the
desired level of agility that
cloud--
consuming new services and
building cloud-native services
promised, we need simple
and scalable solution
for connecting and
managing those services.
Private Service Connect focus
on the connectivity aspect
and enables seamless and
private service consumption
to Google Services,
third-party vendor,
or customer-owned services.
Their traffic is never
exposed to the internet,
and it has the same
performance characteristic
of that VM-to-VM traffic.
And we can support any type
of connectivity design,
really making building
network topology and accessing
the service simplier.
So now that we can connect
to all services easily,
we need a way to
manage them at scale.
So now I'm going
to hand off to Matt
to go through service
directory with you guys.
MATT DELORIA: Thanks, Pierre.
My name's Matt Deloria.
I am the tech lead
of service directory.
This is a product
that we were launch--
that we released to
public beta this spring.
And I'm really excited to
share with everyone here
what we've been doing
with this product
and how it fits
into Google Cloud.
So with Service Directory,
what we were seeing
is that managing
services, as enterprises
adopt a more service-oriented
architecture,
becomes really
challenging to manage.
So what we're noticing
is that customers
are deploying services
to both not just on GCP,
but they still have some legacy
services that they keep on-prem
or, even within GCP, they
may be running services
across different environments.
So a customer may not just
choose one particular product,
like GKE, they may choose
a handful of products,
whether that's being
Cloud Functions,
Cloud Run, or just legacy
VMs or load balance services.
So it was really
challenging for customers
to manage their entire
service inventory.
So we introduced
Service Directory
to help solve this problem.
So with Service Directory,
you can publish, discover,
and connect all
of your services,
regardless of their
environment or whether or not
they're running on GCP,
third-party cloud, or on-prem.
More importantly, it also
can scale to thousands
of services and endpoints.
It can serve real-time
information about your services
to any of your--
both your applications and
the users of your service,
whether that actually be the
teams that are deploying them
or organizations that
they're being shared with.
But you're like, what does
Service Directory really
enable?
And there's, I think,
three kind of core tenants
of what of Service Directory
enables for enterprises.
The first is that it's a way to
discover and publish services
from anywhere, right?
And this is a really
powerful thing.
So no matter where
your services are,
where they're running, where
their applications are,
you can always know you can
reach out to Service Directory
to find them.
So Service Directory
has a couple
of ways that this is really
leverages many of the features
within GCP to do this.
So Service Directory
has a DNS integration
where-- so if you change or
register any of your services
to Service Directory,
these services
become available over
DNS within seconds.
We also expose a really
rich HTP and gRPC API
that allows clients that
need to query using metadata
and things like that and be
able to do that without having
to be on Google's network.
Similarly, Search
Directory offers a way
to catalog your
service architecture.
And what we mean
here is that, so, we
have services that
are spread across
many different environments.
And this has challenges that,
where does a service live?
Where does a service live?
Where is-- like what
region is it in?
What type of service is it?
Is it a replica?
Is it a leader?
What kind of policies are
associated with the service
to make consumption
of services simple?
So at Service Directory,
you have a single place
where you can then actually
attach attributes, attach
metadata, attach policies, where
you can enable all of this.
And you can do this all from
through a-- through our API,
or you can also do this through
Google Developer Console.
And the other important
thing about Service Directory
is that it's also a
way to share services.
So organizations, generally, or
an enterprise, their services
may have to be shared, or they
may have to be restricted.
So I may only want a specific
team within my organization
to be able to produce
our consumer service,
or I may have to share with
a third party, which I've
[INAUDIBLE] into a partnership.
At Service Directory,
that's really simple.
You can restrict services
with IAM policies
and B2C Service controls to be
ensured that the right people
are connected to your services.
And lastly, I think one of
the most important things
is that Service Directory
is completely managed.
So a lot of ways enterprises
have been dealing
with this problem
today are either
by deploy their own software,
write their own software,
or use static files to kind
of register their services
or have to deploy
open-source plugins.
These can be really
challenging to run,
and this is actually a
really critical piece
of infrastructure.
So what we want is
for customers not
have to worry about
running this at all.
So with Service
Directory, so you
get a very simple
way and completely
managed way of
registering your services,
but also knowing that it's
integrated across our platform,
so you have integrations
with Stackdriver, our G Cloud
and API libraries, and also,
of course, developer console.
So here's, really, a kind of
way that Service Directory can
be used in enterprises today.
So what I want to
really focus on here
is that there are really two
aspects to Service Directory.
On the right-hand
side, we have the ways
of things can be published
at Service Directory.
So it doesn't matter--
if looking here, that doesn't
matter what type of service
it is, whether or not it's
GKE or multi-cluster GKE,
whether it's a Google Cloud
API, whether it's on-prem.
All of these services
can be registered
in the Service Directory.
And a lot of these things
can be-- can be very simply
done just by, when you create
the resource, by actually
specifying the service
directory name.
And then from there,
Service Directory will--
if desired, can push
things to private zone DNS.
And we also use IAM to
verify that both producers
and the consumers
of these services
have the correct
permissions to do so.
Now, on the consumer
side, you can
see that it doesn't matter which
type of application it is--
everybody can query--
[INAUDIBLE] to the API.
So if I'm running
on the VPC, I have
a way of using DNS to actually
look this up via DNS, via SRV,
or A records.
Or I can use the HTP or gRPC API
if I'm both out of the network
or on our on-prem data site.
Last slide, so what are we
doing with Service Directory?
So as you saw in many of
the previous slides, some
of the integrations
that we are doing,
these will be-- we
would be starting
to relay out this year.
We're really
building integrations
with-- when you create an
internal load balancer,
they'll be
automatically registered
to Service Directory.
Same with GKE services--
we're also going to be adding
some open source tooling
to kind of make it really
simple for developers
to be able to publish into
Service Directory using
the tooling that
they have today.
We're also now announcing
partnerships with-- we had one,
recently, with
Cisco that has just
announced as part of
Google Cloud Next, where
Cisco's SD1 offering's going
to be using Service Directory's
ability to inform the
location of services.
And Cisco is using us to inform
network topologies and policies
of SD-WAN services.
And now for Private
Service Connect--
so Service Directory is playing
a really-- a critical role here
in the Private
Service Connect, where
private services
will be registered
to Service Directory.
And I'm going to allow Pierre
to talk a little bit more
about why this is
so important, how
this is a very different
way of approaching services.
PIERRE ETTORI: Thanks, Matt.
So Private Service Connect
and Service Directory
combined together
really were hand-in-hand
and provide a better together
story where access to service
is now easy,
secure, and private,
no matter if the
traffic is coming
from on-prem or in the cloud.
And as companies connect
to more and more services
across Google Services,
third-party vendor,
and their own services,
Service Directory really
helps ensuring team
to manage publishing
and discovering services,
allowing technology team
to deliver services faster
and more securely at scale.
So really see Private Service
Connect and Service Directory
as kind of like foundation for
the service-centric networking
solution that
Google is offering.
And we are excited to
have you guys try too.
And with that, I would
like two thank Matt
for presenting with me today.
MATT DELORIA: Thanks, Pierre.
Thanks everyone today
for learning more
about Service Directory.
PIERRE ETTORI: Thanks,
all, for your time.
I hope you learned a lot today
about Private Service Connect
and Service Directory.
We're excited for you guys
to start testing our product.